what's up guys it's another new week and
that means there's a lot of new games
coming out we're going to talk about
them right now one of the big ones is
the division we also got a new hitman
series of coming out episodic form and
Casey Powell across you're not going to
miss that all right let's start with the
heavy hitter Tom Clancy's the division
it takes place in a mid pandemic
Manhattan an open world with destructive
environments for you or the law the dark
zone is the player versus player
competitive multiplayer version where
you can get some real good loot but you
gotta leave with it in order to keep it
players can be accompanied by several
co-op partners and other neutral
player-controlled agents these people
however can turn against you at any
moment at any time already on any reason
on 8 asian 47 is back and he's in his
prime with hitman this is an
ever-expanding game that gives players
new contracts and challenges to complete
every week and they're releasing this
content weekly because it's seasonal the
season premiere the first episode on
March 11th and it continues to add
episodes over time you can start
assassinating on pc ps4 and xbox one on
the 11th now you remember the beloved
game Ori and the blind forest from last
year right well exactly one year from
the date of its release you're getting
the enhanced edition it adds an all-new
blackroot burroughs section of the game
which expands on the titles original or
there's an all-new dashing ability that
can be upgraded throughout the adventure
eventually letting you burst about mid
air and adding a light first explosive
attack basically making you a dashing
grenade a hard mode will increase the
challenge and truly insane can attempt
the one life mode you go back to the
forest on the 11th
in remote island paradise 16 contestants
have 20 minutes to explore scavenge
items craft weapons build traps hunt and
kill each other yes it is the Hunger
Games I was going to tell you more about
this interesting game called the culling
and that it was coming out on the 8th
but they went in ahead and just released
it unexpectedly last week it's out its
out right now so you can go and get it
if this is up your alley gotta mention
moon hunters is very beautiful 14 player
mythology building action RPG you're
literally hunting for the moon along the
way you journey through a world that's
different every time and you make
decisions and show your personality
those traits determine your reputation
but also how you remembered in legend
after you're gone if you're truly
memorable you might even be a symbol of
heroism a constellation in the night sky
visible in all future playthroughs hunt
that moon on the 10th finally I got a
mention Casey Powell across 16 it's
totally coming out this week you're
gonna want to grab this bad boy to hear
sick commentary like it would grab the
second corridor spoon and rolled over
the goal line extended goalie tried to
chew it but couldn't rip for a left post
caught the reba mcentire sneeze bottom
cheese through the five hole yeah
lacrosse that's out on the 9th let me
know down in the comments below what
you're most interested in playing this
week I'm actually really interested in
moon hunters because I love couch co-op
games and that's it remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and sometimes they change I'll
see you next week
you